dans l'enceinte Rouge et Or la cérémonie
de clôture du Parti communiste chinois
est un événement chorégraphié au quart
de tours
un incident semble avoir fait craquer le
vernis reluisant du Congrès quand des
employés ont demandé à l'ancien
président rude de quitter sa place on
l'empêche de saisir ces documents
l'employé insiste en l'agrippant sous le
bras il semble finalement obtempérer
contre son gré devant l'air impassible
du Président si
des points de surprise pour personne
mais ça fait de chez jimping clairement
le leader le plus important le plus
influent le plus puissant depuis
mausédant qui est mort en 1976 pour se
maintenir au pouvoir l'homme fort de la
Chine avait fait supprimer de la
Constitution la limite de demandeurs le
Congrès du Parti communiste s'est
déroulé sur fond de ralentissement
économique et de tension avec l'Occident
le gouvernement devrait aussi maintenir
sa stratégie zéro covid malgré ses
conséquences sur les industries et la
population ici Mélissa François
Radio-Canada Montréal
et on poursuit avec Guy Saint-Jacques
ancien ambassadeur du Canada en Chine
bonsoir Monsieur Saint-Jacques
donc quoi penser tout d'abord de cette
scène étonnante dans le cadre d'un
événement hyper chorégraphié
mais moi j'ai trouvé ça
extraordinaire parce que j'ai jamais
rien vu de ça puis en fait si on regarde
aussi d'autres systèmes communistes
comme à l'époque de l'Union soviétique
j'ai jamais rien vu comme ça parce que
c'est en fait c'est que c'est la réunion
du Parti communiste le secrétaire
général du parti si Jean Ping a obtenu
tout ce qu'il voulait lors du congrès
rue Jean tard manifestement n'était pas
d'accord avec ça et peut-être que le
monsieur si a créé que woodinter veuille
faire un coup d'éclat
si les gens qui sont nés
enlever Monsieur Roux ont attendu que
tous les journalistes soient en position
pour que ça soit filmé une humiliation
comme ça c'est une perte de face à
envers un leader qui était dans la même
position que c'est une pigne il y a à
peine 10 ans et de posséder comme ça moi
je pense que ça va créer beaucoup de
d'amertume de ressentiment parmi les
gens qui
du parti parce que pourquoi faire ça
publiquement pourquoi humilier une
personne on voit comment aussi les
autres dirigeants qui étaient assis
comment ils étaient mal à l'aise l'autre
message c'est à la société chinoise
c'est de dire regardez je suis
maintenant en charge de tout et il faut
que vous fassiez ce que je vous demande
de faire ça s'applique aussi bien au
secteur privé à tout le monde donc il y
a plein de choses que vous venez de dire
dans le fond c'est que bon les médias
officiels chinois eux ont indiqué qu'ils
ne se sentaient pas bien alors on peut
peut-être remettre en question on verra
bien pourquoi ce serait-il ça pourquoi
on se serait empressé en fait de
censurer le nom de hudgetao par exemple
sur les réseaux sociaux après cet
événement c'est ce qu'on rapporte et le
symbole est très fort aussi faire
disparaître son prédécesseurs qui
étaient reconnus pour comme étant un
réformateur donc c'est comme si on est
face à une partie du passé
tout à fait puis en fait on sait que il
y a des factions au sein du sport
communiste c'est pas un parti
monolithique l'autre grand absent de
cette de ce congrès c'est l'ancien
président qui a 96 ans qui dans l'état
de santé est trop mauvais pour qu'il
puisse assister mais là c'était un
message clair à toutes les autres
factions
il est trop tard pour vous opposer c'est
moi le nouveau grand patron et je suis
tellement fort que je peux poser ce
geste humiliant je trouve ça immature de
la part de c'est une et des événements
qui pourraient refroidir les
investisseurs étrangers qu'ils sont des
gens par la politique zéro covid de
c'est jumping
oui tout à fait puis en fait aussi déjà
dans le secteur privé chinois il y a
beaucoup d'inquiétudes parce que au
cours des dernières années le président
est intervenu pour mettre des contrôles
sur les grandes compagnies comme Alibaba
ou Didi il a parlé de cette notion de
prospérité commune de redistribution de
la richesse et les échos que j'ai de ces
de beaucoup d'entrepreneurs chinois
c'est il se disent
ça commence à être plus difficile de
faire des affaires est-ce que c'est le
tas de quitter et puis le secteur privé
c'est celui qui crée le plus d'emploi en
Chine c'est que donc il risque d'avoir
des répercussions là bien sûr auprès des
compagnies étrangères mais aussi de
fortes répercussions enchaînement
économique merci beaucoup monsieur
Saint-Jacques d'avoir été avec nous
encore une fois au revoir merci au
revoir